now you see me too is a sequel to now
you see me which as you can tell is a
guilty pleasure of mine this movie is
kind of dumb but it's gleefully dumb
like there's a lot of that happens
it doesn't make sense and you kind of
are left scratching your head but the
movie is so self-aware of itself and
just wants to have fun that you can kind
of roll with it now you see me to once
again has the four horsemen back except
one of them is no longer isla Fisher
because apparently she was dealing with
the pregnancy during this filming so she
has been replaced with Lizzy Caplan and
these guys have been drawn into a game
by Daniel Radcliffe's character who
claims that he has been financially
harmed severely by what they did in the
first film so Jesse Eisenberg Woody
Harrelson dave Franco Lizzy Caplan and
Mark Ruffalo who are all teamed up as
the various Forsman now have to figure
out a way to get out of this situation
while also revealing Daniel Radcliffe's
character for who he really is like I
said the first film was stupid there was
a lot of magic in it that didn't make
sense like they jumped off of a rooftop
and turned into playing cards somehow
but it was well directed enough and well
acted enough to the point where you
could get into it and at least kind of
gleefully go along with it and have fun
with this movie I was hoping it would be
the same way I'm moving to just totally
knew what it was it was ready to go and
it was ready to have fun and
entertaining you and in some ways it
does it's a loud very fast movie with a
lot of really flashy things happening
but for me it was sort of like a
magician that you enjoy watching but
there's just nothing really there in his
act he might pull a rabbit out of a hat
he might have a dove fly out of
somebody's coat and that might impress
you and it might be visually interesting
for one second but you almost
instantaneously forget about it the
second you do something else and that's
kind of what now you see me too was like
for me
there's tons of flashy big sequences but
none of them really add up to anything
we have so many great actors in this
movie and Mark Ruffalo for me carried
the entire thing he has the most
heartfelt story in this movie his
character is given the most reason I
guess for being there all of the other
characters just kind of felt like
contractually obligated characters
Ruffalo had a reason to be in this movie
he had motivation he had something
driving him his character was by far the
best in this film and his performance
for me was the best in this film he was
awesome
favorite part of the first movie as far
as characters go the rest really don't
have much going on let's talk about
woody harrelson in this movie he's one
of my favorite actors and something that
hasn't been marketed that much is that
he also plays his exact twin in this
film who I wouldn't describe as the Jar
Jar Binks of the now you see me
franchise but he is really annoying he's
not on that level but they just kept
bringing him back in this movie and just
really didn't work
there's also horrific Lee horrendous
editing throughout this movie that
actually started to get on my nerves
there's a shot with Woody Harrelson's
character he's putting his sunglasses on
and he starts to put his hands down and
his hands are here we come to the next
shot and he's standing completely
straight like this it's a wide shot so I
guess they're not expecting us to be
looking for that but when you examine
film and you really look for stuff like
that it starts to become noticeable
there was an absurd amount of continuity
errors in this film where people would
just be in different positions as shots
cut together and usually I don't look
for that kind of thing because I
understand that mistakes happen it's
hard to make a movie but when a movie
with this type of budget with this type
of caliber of actors and a studio behind
it does that and I notice it because I'm
not the person usually looks for that
kind of stuff and it happens a lot
that's not good and it wasn't like the
way Scorsese does it Scorsese in his
films does a lot of intentional
continuity errors to make you feel
slightly off kilter make you feel like
you're watching something that is you
know in a way dreamlike it wasn't like
that
the director Jon M Chu who made step up
three a dance film that I actually
thought was a lot better than it had any
right to be directs this film and you
can kind of tell that it was just
mistakes I haven't really gotten to my
biggest gripe with this film though the
first film as I said didn't really make
a lot of sense it was kind of dumb but
it was so fun and self-aware that you
can sort of just forget about it even
though a lot of things that happen
you're just like yeah no this film
starts to take itself seriously it has a
heartfelt story behind Ruffalo's
character which did work for his
character but then the film starts to
get to a point where it was just really
a series of completely unexplainable
absurd events where people use CGI magic
and then there'd be a sequence where
they explained it elaborately to
everyone but all the things they
explained were all the things that I
didn't need explained they step out and
they're just like here's how we did
everything and I'm like yeah I could
tell I saw the obvious hints to all of
these things now please explain to me
how Jesse Eisenberg vanished and turned
into water there are tons of moments
like that in this movie and there comes
a point where you either just roll with
it
or you sit there being that skeptic guy
that's like no and I'm not that guy I
actually am the guy who likes to look up
at the sky and see a dot and think oh is
that a UFO
I love stuff like that when I watch a
movie like this though I just see
writers who are like we can get away
with that because you know CGI and then
when a character comes forth and says
how does that happen and Morgan Freeman
is like well that's a good question I'm
Morgan Freeman you just kind of have to
believe me because just listen to the
sound of my voice the film just becomes
flimsy and deflates on itself that being
said you can watch this movie it's a
totally watchable movie it's two hours
or whatever and it goes by fairly fast
it's just that the movie feels as if
it's making itself up as it goes along
like the writers were constantly looking
for reasons to have the characters in
this movie besides the fact that they
want a trilogy and eventually they'll
probably get it if this movie does well
I'm going to give now you see me to a
c-minus it's not as good as the first
one because the first one didn't take
itself so seriously this one is not as
streamlined the story isn't as good the
first one felt like a movie you could
watch and just sort of eat popcorn and
forget about the stupid things that were
happening this one takes itself a little
too seriously
so guys stay tuned for this weekend
because yes I'm going to upload my rant
on Annoying moviegoers part 2 because
I've had some terrible experiences
recently and therapy through video form
is surprisingly wonderful I've already
filmed it and I can't wait to share that
with you guys as well as my Captain
America the 1990 version hilarious 'ti
on Sunday you guys are the best thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes